Can someone get me out of here please?
Can someone get me out of this box?
What am I?
A piece of candy?
I know my name is Mint but hello!
Are you guys ready to get this party started?
Yeah!
Let's go!
Can
one guy be?
I kissed her and she kissed me said, ain't that a kick in
the head?
The room was completely black.
I hugged her and she hugged back.
Like a sinner said, quote, ain't that a hole in the boat?
My head keeps spinning.
I go to sleep.
I keep grinning.
If this is just the beginning, my life is gonna be Beautiful
I'm sunshine enough to spread It's just like the filler said
Tell me quick, ain't love a kick in the head Woo!
My
head keeps spinning I go to sleep, I keep grinning If this
is just the beginning
Be beautiful, she's telling me we'll be wed.
She's picked out a king-size bed.
I couldn't feel any better or I'd be sick.
Tell me quick, oh, ain't love a kick?
Tell me quick, ain't love a kick in the head.
oh my gosh look at me i'm like a i'm like a mime in a box
it's kind of crazy but yes welcome everybody thank you so
much for coming out to this show thank you for being patient
with the delays and everything i'm so so sorry but oh my
gosh give it a big big round of applause for our band yay
so i'm so nervous if i mess up no i didn't okay but thank
you but also did you guys think like me made outfit doesn't
really like suit the venue right you don't think so right
band could i get a little bit of a drum roll please
yay oh my gosh i feel i feel like i'm playing dress up like
i don't but yeah we have a great show for you guys tonight
and of course our special guests and i'm singing some songs
you've heard before and some new songs as well so i hope
that you guys cheer cheer on with all your might okay yeah
okay dukey all right are we ready band are we ready team
yeah okie dokie let's get into it
love me as though there were no tomorrow Take me out of this
world tonight.
Take me, make me forget my sorrow.
So when I wake tomorrow, I'll know our love was right.
Kiss me as though it were now or never.
Teach me all that a heart should know.
Love me as though there were no tomorrow.
Oh my darling, love me.
Don't ever let me go.
Love me as though there were no tomorrow.
My darling, love me.
Never let me go.
Hello everyone, I hope you're having a wonderful time today.
The name is Miri Celesta, your local Izakai guild leader and
adventurer on duty.
It is such a huge honor for me to be able to sing here
today.
We are happy to present to you.
I've got you under my skin.
I've
got you under my skin.
I've got you deep in the heart of me.
You're so deep in my heart, you're really a part of me.
I've got you under my skin.
I've tried so not to give in I've said to myself this affair
never will go so well But why should I try to resist when
darling I know so well But I've got you under my skin I'd
sacrifice anything, come what might, for the sake of having
you near In spite of a warning voice that comes in at the
night And repeats and repeats in my ear Don't you know,
little fool, you never can win Use your mentality, wake up
to reality But each time that I do, just the thought of you
makes me stop before I begin.
Because I've got you under my skin.
You never can win.
Use your mentality.
But each time that I do, just the thought of you makes me
stop before I begin.
Because I've got you under my skin.
And I'll love you under my skin.
Under my skin.
Yes, I've got you under my skin.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, beauty.
Thank you, thank you.
It was so lovely seeing you here today.
Hope you enjoyed the rest of the show.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you to the lovely beauty, Celesto.
One more round of applause for her.
When I was thinking of the show, I was like, I must invite
Miori because her voice is just, oh, she, her jazz is so
good, so, I'm really happy to have been able to sing with
her, so, yes, yes, yes, oh, I'm so nervous, you guys, oh,
thank you, oh, but yeah, we still have, what, chicken,
what'd you say?
Stabby, stabby.
Stabby.
Okay, are you guys ready for some more?
Yes!
Oh, wiki, oki.
I almost said alright and oki-doki at the end.
I was like, o-riki-do-riki.
Oki-doki, let's continue onwards to the next song!
This song, I chose because, you know, it's Valentine's Day,
but Some people don't have a Valentine, so it's okay.
In my solitude, you honed to me with reveries of dead gone
by
in my solitude you taunt me with memories that never die
I sit in my chair I'm filled with despair There's no one
could be so sad With gloom everywhere I sit and I stare I
know that I'll soon go home back.
In my solitude,
I'm praying.
Dear Lord, above, send back my love.
Dear Lord above, send back my love.